there's something i want to say which is
today
for the first time ever i was out
driving around and i realized hey i've
never seen sona's home
sona has a home that she purchased just
before kovid
yep and i've wanted to see it and it's a
bit
far from where i live but i was kind of
sort of quasi near that area and i
thought i'll stop by so i called sona
and she said sure come on over
she was chatting with me on the phone
and i was talking to her in the car
saying
i'll head your way i think i know the
way i'm following google maps
i think i can get there with your
address and we're chatting
and i thought she said i'm cleaning up
while you come over just tidying up a
bit
and then i heard a noise in the
background that sounded like something
shutting and i said
oh did you just close like a microwave
that's what it sounded like you just
close the microwave
and sona said something that caught my
attention she said no
i'm armenian we don't have microwave
ovens
what and i don't know what that means
and she wasn't making a joke and then
she said no tech my husband's armenian
too
so we don't have microwaves and i
thought this i have to explore
okay why don't armenian people have
microwaves i'm not doing i'm curious
yeah i am too i never grew up with one
neither did tac
you go to our parents house nobody has a
microwave i can't speak for all
armenians but i think
i think most armenians that i've houses
that i've been to
you don't reheat the food by putting it
in a box
and zapping it for a minute you put it
back on the stove and you basically
re-cook it
and it is laborious like a little
judgment there
i'm just saying it's like do i want that
radiation in my house i don't know i
kind of
oh first of all there's not radiation
shooting out of a microwave
uh that they fixed that problem two
years ago uh
the point i'm making that that this i'm
curious about this because this felt
like a window into a real thing
you weren't making a joke but my parents
it's not a generational thing because
my parents are much older uh than
than your parents uh my father's like i
think he's 128 years old
he is one of the oldest men to ever live
and he has had we've had a microwave in
our house since
like the late 70s huh so it's not a
generational thing
is it matt it's not generational
something and sona do you think it might
be
cultural that yeah that your culture
doesn't believe in
putting it in a microwave because that's
cheating somehow
it also you have to admit that when you
reheat something in a microwave
it's not the same so you know
i wouldn't know i've only reheated
things in a microwave okay
i'm serious i i'm completely dependent
on a microwave i take there's leftover
food
my wife's a very good cook and she makes
stuff
and it's in these tupperware containers
and i
open it and i put it on a plate and then
i put it in the microwave and i put
everything on two minutes i don't care
what it is i put it on two minutes
um and then i always forget reach in and
grab the plate with my bare hands
oh burning the skin on my hands i do
this every single time
a squid will learn instantly once it's
stung
not to approach that object again i
went to a good college and every time i
reach in
grab it and as my flesh sears
still that's what i do with everything i
microwave everything
and i don't know how you can live
without a microwave i just never you
know what when we when we were growing
up
there was a microwave that was old that
someone had
that was in the garage that no one used
the only time
that i ever used it was i would take it
down from the shelf that we were using
it to
where we stored it and i would heat up
the wax that i would use to wax my lips
what i'm sorry wait a minute yeah and
couldn't you have done that in the oven
no cause it's it's different that's
that's the wax it needs a microwave i
don't know
how to reheat wax in the microwave but
that was it i never
needed it i mean everything i'm sorry i
don't know anything about this you have
to heat up
wax and you put it on your legs yeah
and then you pull it off yeah that's
waxing
yeah that's what was sewn you don't know
any
i don't wax do you wax matt oh yeah oh
no okay i don't know
listen we got off track a little bit
there you mentioned
sona that you mentioned something that
intrigues me you said
who needs all that radiation
and do you really think there's a lot of
radiation coming out of a microwave
it's there's so much around us just in
general
that i'm kind of like do i need
something else
not really and i i i'm telling you right
now i've never lived with a microwave
tack has never lived with it can i ask
you a question yeah can you ask your
question does this have anything to do
with the fact that your husband and this
is a true story
went to a summer camp that was near
chernobyl okay
seriously so tak grew up in the soviet
union which you know he was there since
until he was 11. he had absolutely no
involvement
in chernobyl no one's blaming him
i'm not blaming tac for chernobyl but
you told me that he went to a summer
camp
that was near chernobyl also the way you
responded and said that he had nothing
to do with it now
he didn't blame you makes me think did
he have something to do with you
he wasn't anywhere in the ukraine when
chernobyl happened
that just seems like you're protesting
too much no it's just conan's like oh
ukraine soviet union oh
no that is not me no tap was uh
right there on the bridge watching the
plant uh you know it
just implode i watch the hbo
movie which is very moving and there's a
scene
where there's a young where there's a
young boy and they say tack
get out of here and he says someday i
marry sona he says that
he says someday i marry sona that's and
you're wondering like why is this even
in the script because it's not a
documentary
and he's holding a pivotal part of the
reactor that he's taken yeah he's
holding a piece of reactor he had just
this is the way i had always heard the
story tack was on a school trip
they went to chernobyl to see the plant
they said don't touch anything
tech said what's in this room and they
said tack you irrepressible
scamp you stay out of that room tack
went in there
removed an important cooling rod and
walked out
of the reactor it exploded creating one
of the worst nuclear disasters ever
after which tak fled the soviet union
came to america married you and then
you said maybe we should get a microwave
and he said who needs a microwave watch
this
and he just put his hand over the food
okay
yeah yeah yeah you're stupid that's
tech's origin story let's sell that to
marvel i will say
listen when we were watching chernobyl
and you talk about tech
having grown up in the soviet union
union a lot the whole time we were like
[ __ ] we know conan's gonna watch this
and we know he's gonna have all kinds of
material
and then when they introduced an
armenian character whose sole purpose
was to kill
dogs oh and other animals that was awful
the whole time you ruined that viewing
experience for us like how does that
feel
because how did i because everything i
look at in my life now is like how can
kona make a riff of this
and jokes about this no i never went
after attack
in any way related to that was too
horrifying to me i really i
i i did not joke about that but the
minute i realized
that tak had had gone to a summer camp
pretty much at chernobyl i realized i ha
how do i
not mention that how do i not mention
that and that he can reheat
he makes ramen noodles just by cupping
his hands
you can put the noodles inside i've seen
him do it he does it at parties it's fun
he's this is one division you know
you're he's
vision you're wanda because you're
witch-like at times
oh wow no i'm saying that in which
liking that you have powers son that was
a compliment
okay when i say you're a real witch i
mean you have a lot of powers you are
not
you are uh outside the norm those are
all compliments and when i say that he's
vision i mean he was responsible for the
chernobyl accident
and uh he was a boy he was irradiated
and now he can make ramen noodles in his
hands
that's all i'm saying there's no insult
in here at all
there's no insult there's no
exaggeration there's no goofing around
oh everything you're saying is true okay
thank you we have your admission